Maybe that's what the doctor said, but it's out of the question Let's take England to Ku-sama's place as soon as
possible  He started saying that he would follow me, so
yeah,
I came here on my own will,
but I tried to make him believe me by pretending that I did.
This woman is
beautiful, but I can't trust him.
It's strange that quartz suddenly becomes like this
What do you think?
I said I'd be with
you, but I don't want to get caught by you guys
Come on [music] Hold on Wait great, let's hear March You can trust me I guarantee
Skiing
He's
just like us
Surrounded by my friends in the village,
I've actually been feeling lonely all this
time.
So what happened
just now is a secret between the two
of
us Now we're friends too